hello welcome to this video playing
clear blue water let's see what that is
no name okay yeah what can i play has a
night off which is not already
theoretical there are all kinds of wacky
moves in our days that right no I've
seen that keenya 3 is actually played
once in a while well I'm not saying that
this is the best line ever but it does
make some sense it's not completely
completely completely bonkers the FG 595
now that cannot be too bad ok so here
I'm the Bishop to e2 is probably right
eyeing this strand at night on edge file
yeah just back
just back I'm not very afraid yet he
might be able to take now here but I'm
kind of I'm not really afraid cannot be
great early giving me the dark squared
bishop okay so Bishop g4 now for trading
and II 595 was unplayable so yes he has
to take basically maybe before
mine looks pretty bad that's what's it
doing that before me I still FYI right
move yeah 92 I guess taking I just go
here now g3 attacking that poor now can
be good doesn't he have to play Knight
c4 almost don't see an alternative okay
that that's possible keys on this one
for now for f5 preparing at five maybe
five now
maybe if I they almost has to I would
have thought he has to it obviously not
hmm yeah isn't taking first I mean
nightmare maybe you can move the night
okay it's not totally out of the picture
yeah maybe check but it did not happen
yeah here Queen over to d4 should be
strong I just wonder that can also just
take these six which is quite okay
and I like this as well Queen to d4
strong pushup you for Queen D four wins
apiece so check here and some system f6
or check I always have cosplay c3 here
okay it still a little bit murky
still somewhat murky this position even
though night XD six should be a pretty
huge threat here
and honestly I don't see a move here for
him Knight takes t6 even if he goes
route the eighth i just take it probably
that tech is too strong ya can take it
27 I win I def 7am did I overlooked
something don't know but I'm always
taking root p8 check check
now we got a thunderstorm here coming up
sounds quite loud so just lay our way
here to play for made night chick came
back check your sent mail check check
check mate ok that worked out well this
opening really got a great position I
can I have to say I cannot really give
you any big advice I only know that this
is a move that has been played but by
some strong players mostly in in nine
blitz chess and and rapid and things
like that but I have absolutely no clue
if this is any good or not so I'm fairly
certain that this the screen 85 maneuver
is not probably the best one cannot
believe that this can be helpful here to
get this night pushed on the on the edge
of the board and get the night to do
five okay I went with this yeah computer
is fearless as usual wants to take care
yeah I was just gambling that this is
not happening people tend to value with
that dark squared bishop often higher
then computers do computer likes black
here I'm not saying that is that's not
the case just I was just gambling here a
little bit yeah again he could have
taken I don't think you can afford to do
this this looks very day very risky can
start with the capture and then I
thought Bishop before
but also root these six is actually
possible the night is covering this of
course yeah here I cancel and this and
this must be excellent now really yeah
the computer likes white here a lot yeah
I thought each five maybe the computer
kind of agrees it says I'm better but
not winning yeah the effort time winning
36 immediately was also strong okay
check this should be should be enough
you know yeah the engine term gives me a
win here yeah so that that worked out
there are a couple of weird of alliance
against maintenance aliens and
increasingly often they involve only
queen moves queen f 3 23 so it really
isn't all that bad those offbeat moves
ok guys thanks for watching